-Thank you.
-So, you made a documentar
about white privilege.
-I did. My own, specifically
-Your own specific
white privilege.
And this is was an idea you ha
post-2016 election.
-Postmortem, I -- Yes.
And in 2016,
I don't know if you guys know,
there was an election.
-[ Chuckles ] Yeah.
-A pretty big one.
I didn't like the way that went.
-Yeah.
-So, I had a hard time with it
And, you know,
before the election,
like, my biggest decision wa
whether I was gonna build
a slide that came out
of my bedroom balcony for adults
that went straight into my pool.
That was, like,
my biggest stressor.
And then, the day
after the election,
I was running around
my neighborhood
passing out water bottles
to Mexican workers
like, "We love you.
You're here. You belong here."
They're like, "We're legally
here, so back off, bitch."
[ Laughter ]
So it was a confusing time
-Yes.
-And I was very upset,
and I dug deep, and I went
to therapy for the first time.
-Yeah.
-The first real time in my lif
at the tender age of 42,
I think.
And I got real
about my entitlement,
about being spoiled,
about what it's like
to look outside of yourself,
get your head out
of your own ass, you know?
And I started to look around
and realized just how bad,
like, of bad shape we were i
and how little I knew about it
So I got educated.
-And with white privilege,
this was something that,
is it safe to say you were
a little just oblivious to
before you had
this sort of introspection
-Yeah. Like, I thought,
"Oh, I'm super talented,
and I work really hard.
That's why I'm successful.
It's like "Whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa."
When you start to read books
it's like
a person of color wouldn't hav
had the career I've had,
wouldn't have gotten away
with the things I got away with,
and I had no
accountability for that.
So for me, it was a deep div
into just understanding
what it's like to be a perso
of color in this country,
as good of an understandin
as I can have,
because, obviously,
I can't understand.
But I wanted to do something
that wasn't about
me collecting a paycheck.
It was about communicating
and just contributing something,
you know, in a more
thoughtful way.
So I started with
my own ridiculous privileg
and lifestyle,
which is, you know, absurd
So I learned a lot,
and we have to really
pay attention
to people that are unlike us
-And I think, you know, I feel
similar probably to you,
which is, you know, you,
as a white person, you succeed
and it felt very hard, you know,
when you are in it
and your perspective.
And you just need to realize
like, "Oh, I'm not saying
white privilege doesn't mean
it was easy for you.
It just means
it can be so much harder
for people that don't have
that first step in the door.
-Absolutely. It means that whe
I get pulled over by the cops,
I don't have to worry about it
being a life-or-death situation.
-Which is a huge difference.
-Exactly, so --
-You mentioned --
One of things you talk about
is shoplifting,
how that is something you di
which then becomes
a slap on the wrist
as opposed to what it could be
for someone else.
-Yeah, I mean, my ex-boyfriend's
in the documentary.
He's a black man named Tyshawn
I dated when I was 16.
And I know everybody knows
that I've dated 50 cent,
and my friend said, "Oh, great
Now people are gonna think
you only like black guys
and you discriminate
against your own race."
So I would like to say tha
I'm available to white men, too.
-That's very nice of you to say.
-Okay?
I want it clear that I don't
discriminate against white men
-That is very sweet of you
[ Laughter ]
-Even though, you know,
you guys know what you did
[ Laughter ]
Um, but --
Wait, what was
the question? Sorry.
-Shoplifting.
-Oh, shoplifting.
Well, he and I got caught,
"A," with three dime bags
when we were 16, he was 18
Every time, they let me go
and every time, he got arrested.
And he ended up spending
14 years in jail.
And I never thought about that
at the time.
My director of this documentar
made me go back there
and revisit that.
I was like, "No more
ex-boyfriends."
Like, "I've met up with a
couple, and it doesn't go well."
So I wasn't that into it.
But it was important.
And, you know,
there are examples.
I mean, I've walked
into an airport.
You know how annoying
an airport can be,
and the slowness
of a transaction
with the person
behind the counter
or at a Hudson Bookseller.
I mean, I've definitely
walked in, looked at her
and looked at the slowness
of the transaction
of what it was going to take
taken a book, and just waved $20
up at the -- up at the camera --
the security camera
and be like, "Yeah, I'm taking
this, and I'm leaving.
I can't deal
with the slowness of this.
And when I was talking
to her about that,
I go, "Is that white privilege?"
She's like, "No, white peopl
aren't even doing that."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-She was like,
"You just have problems."
[ Laughter ]
So it was --
-Yeah, don't pin that
on our race.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
-That is very specifically
a Chelsea thing.
-I was like, "Yeah, it turns out
it is very specifically
a Chelsea thing."
A lot of my issues are very,
you know, centered
around my own experience.
-You were -- You were arrested
when you were 21.
What was that for?
-I got a DUI,
but my sister,
who's in my dressing room,
my mother had given me her I.D.,
like, as one mother does -
as a mother does,
so that I could drink
earlier than I was,
you know, legally able to.
-Sure. Good parenting. Yeah.
-My mom was just like,
"Whatever you need
to get the hell
out of this house."
Like, "If you need a fake I.D.
take it."
Anyway, I got pulled over,
and I forgot
that I was 21 at that point,
'cause it had only been a week
and I gave them my sister's I.D.
And apparently, my sister ha
reported me to, like, the FB
or something, so I had to --
-For stealing your I.D.?
-She -- She was Mormon
at the time.
So, she was really just, like,
out to get me --
-Yeah, they call the FBI
left and right.
-You know how Mormons are.
[ Laughter ]
-They got it on speed dial
Yeah.
-It's like they're in bed
with the FBI, basically.
No, so, I ended up
spending like 48 hours
in this -- in L.A. County
women's prison.
And then I had to go to this
class where you had to get u
and tell your DUI --
You had go to DUI school,
which is basically a schoo
you go to for like 8 to 10 weeks
where they teach you
how to get out of your next DUI.
-Okay.
-They're basically like,
"Don't ever admit --" I'm like
"What kind of class is this?
But when I got up
to finally tell my story
about my experience --
-Were you nervous
about telling your story?
-Yeah, I had diarrhea.
Like, I had diarrhea --
Every time I went to that class,
the fear of getting called on,
I had diarrhea.
-Yeah. Oh, wow.
-Public speaking was the
scariest thing you could imagine
and I was like,
"There's no way I can do this.
I can't talk publicly."
But when I did get up,
I couldn't get back down.
I couldn't stop talking, 'caus
the audience was like with me,
and they were listening to me.
And my story was ridiculous.
I called the cop a racist.
He was white.
I mean, none of it made sense.
And when I got off,
somebody's like,
"You should do stand-up comedy,"
and I was like, "Yeah,
that actually makes sense --
me talking and no one
being able to interrupt."
So, that's kind of
how I got into stand-up.
-So, I guess what you're sayin
that any young potential
stand-ups out there
is get that first DUI.
Get in front of people.
-That's right.
[ Laughter ]
-You know, work it out
in front of an audience.
-Yeah, and if you could
steal someone's I.D.,
go for that, too. Why not?
-Congratulations
on the documentary.
It's always so great to see you.
-Thank you.
-Give it up for Chelsea Handler,
everybody.